[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
r kelly is back on trial from opening
statements to herpes allegations and fan
reactions it's about the money
prosecutors calling the r b singer a
predator how the defense is fighting
back and robert durst faces
cross-examination
the real estate air now admitting he
hasn't always told the truth i lied
the lies the disappearances and deaths
surrounding robert durst
in fact you had killed her
would you tell us no
lawn crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everybody to law and crime daily
i'm jesse weber in our studios brian
buckmeyer is on assignment at r kelly's
trial and with us as always is terry
austin testimony in the highly
anticipated sex crimes trial of the r b
singer has begun now cameras are not
allowed in the courtroom but brian's
there for all of it brian paint the
scene for us what does it look like
outside the courthouse and what can you
tell us about what's happening inside
so for those of you who don't know of
the edny the building right behind me
it's actually right across the street
from a park called cabin plaza and so we
have a number of people just kind of
hanging out sitting in the plaza while
we're sitting here you can hear people
actually singing our kelly's song just
moments ago
we heard someone saying i believe i can
fly
members of the savage family that is
joycelyn savage's
family that is an ex-girlfriend of r
kelly was living with him since she was
19 and is now coming out through social
media saying that she was a victim her
family came in and we saw gloria all
read walking hand in hand with the
family going in now inside we can't be
in the court because of covet
restrictions in fact the jury is not
even in a jury box they're in the
audience spread out and so we're sitting
in an overflow room with cameras all
over that room and we have one camera
directed at r kelly we can see a very
stoic r kelly sometimes writing notes
and whispering to his his counsel or
maybe even co-counsel because it appears
that he's taking a very hands-on
approach to this case we're not seeing
any kind of outbursts or any kind of
reactions when the allegations are put
forward but he's definitely
participating in his defense by helping
out by giving a few notes here and a few
words there
stories don't add up if you follow it it
doesn't add up the stories are different
every time
i met him in the park
then you write a book you met them at a
restaurant which one is you know the
story's not the same you know
don't make sense
at all
none of them
not one of them
it's about the money
all right so you see some fans that are
showing support for r kelly but let's
get to the arguments brian let's start
with the prosecution what did they have
to say during their opening statement
the prosecution had even in this public
defender's opinion a phenomenal opening
statement they started off as you said
calling him a sexual predator that he
targeted these women and groomed them
for his own sexual pleasure but not just
him that he's enterprised that as well
that a system of runners individuals who
may run into assignments for him or pick
up a girl here or drop them off there or
pick up some food or clean up after him
uh that runners as well as producers and
other individuals in his inner circle
that's what they're describing it as uh
used his fame used his money to find and
groom these women for his sexual
pleasure uh and that's what they came
out with and then they listed line by
line we got some of the first names of
some of the alleged victims describing
not only the acts that r kelly allegedly
put upon them but also how they are in
instrumental to certain alleged crimes
being the man act or that of rico
charges but we always know there are two
sides to every trial so we know the
prosecution has a strong case what did
the defense say in their opening
silly it's not just what they said but
how they said it the defense started off
really bumpy with an objection that was
sustained and that was kind of the tenor
of their opening remarks they started
off by almost giving a resume of how
good the defense attorneys were how long
they had practiced and by the second
defense attorney the judge quickly shut
that down then continued by trying their
best to highlight some of the
inconsistencies now in my opinion at
least a lot of it was fluff but some of
it did start to kind of make sense as
they talked about certain instances
specifically about one woman's
allegations of being locked in a room
and the fact that there was a phone in
that room that she had a phone and
without women's allegations that she was
forced to pee in a cup the defense came
out trying to explain that that r kelly
is actually afraid of flying so one he's
on tour he's doing it on a bus and
trying to make the analogy that like
many of us who do road trips for long
extended periods of time we may have to
pee in a cup uh during that and they
were trying to make that correlation to
try to take the sting out of all the
allegations the prosecutions put forward
now a few other objections that were had
were the defense trying to almost vouch
for how good the evidence was in their
in their case and each and every time
the judge brought them up sustaining the
arguments and it was definitely took a
little bit of the wind out of their sail
and i think the jury saw that as well
well focusing on the defense r kelly's
defense attorney thomas faranella he
provided us with this statement quote at
this point the public has only heard one
side of the story in this case and that
is about to change in the coming weeks
we look forward to the truth and the
facts coming to light as the defense
will continue to vigorously defend mr
kelly after all the ricoh enterprise is
based on a series of independent
relationships and events that the
government is trying to patch together
like different types of fabrics and
trying to pass it off as silk okay so
let's get into this terry let's break
down that rico or racketeering charge
very unique it encompasses 14 underlying
acts does the state have to prove all of
that in order to secure a conviction on
racketeering
that's an excellent question jesse and
the answer is no they do not under the
1970 rico act they only need to prove
more than one of those underlying acts
and we know already we have a number of
acts from the 14 count we have bribery
exploitation of a child kidnapping
forced labor we even have six acts of
violation of the man act which is
basically transportation of girls for
prosecution so they just need to prove
two of those underlying acts and they
have acts ranging from 1994 all the way
through 2018 so they can select the ones
they want to try to really enforce and
also they have multiple women who are
saying that they were victims of these
crimes and actually jesse this was a
very smart move on their part so i think
uh they can have lots of evidence and
i'm glad you mentioned that because
brian it's my understanding that jane
doe for testified today what did you
learn
yeah so jane doe number four testified
and one thing that we learned that we
were not supposed to learn and i forgot
to mention this in defense's opening
statements they actually named her not
just her first name but her last name as
well of course we won't do that because
of the protections that victims in this
situation deserve and have but that was
a big hiccup in the defense's opening
statements so we learned her name we
learned about her relationship and we
learned about how r kelly allegedly took
her virginity as a 16 year old girl and
knowing that she was 16 because she
provided a id and said this is
uncomfortable i'm underage and our
kelly's response according to the
prosecution was what does that mean tell
people you're 19 pretend you're 21 right
let's keep doing this
wow
absolutely incredible and there's still
so much to go so still ahead on law and
crime daily robert durst is back on the
witness stand for another round of
questions but this time by the
prosecution but first more on r kelly
the shocking rulings made in court
before the jury was brought in are
reporters on the ground bringing you
exclusive coverage that's next
[Music]
all right welcome back everybody
shocking allegations are continuing to
pour out of the sex crimes trial for r b
singer r kelly long crimes managing
editor adam classfield is there in
brooklyn adam it's good to see you a lot
to talk about first let's talk about
there was a discussion about how herpes
could play a role in this evidence talk
about that
well the biggest thing to come out today
on that subject was the fact that r
kelly's motions to suppress that
evidence and to dismiss those counts
failed the judge judge donnelly quickly
uh rejected those and it's been long
alleged and now was spoke in front of
the jury alleged that r kelly uh
transmitted and infected herpes to
multiple minor victims
well you know what's also very strange
is that you're hearing a lot of big
names and in fact aaliyah aaliyah the
singer who tragically passed away in a
plane crash in 2001 it's my
understanding she plays a very crucial
role in this case as well how is that so
absolutely well this isn't one of the
names that came out during the
prosecution's opening statements uh one
of the biggest parts of what they
claimed to the jury is that he had a
secret marriage to aaliyah after she got
pregnant at the age of 15 she was a
minor and prosecutors allege that
essentially he
uh
to cover
this up to make to have spousal
privilege and avoid a prosecution for
this uh that they
uh had a secret marriage through a fake
id
yeah you just can't make this stuff up
uh adam great reporting thank you so
much we can't wait to have you back to
talk more about this trial um i want to
bring back in co-host terry austin to
talk more about r kelly's trial now
terry
how do you think that this trial is
going to differ from kelly's trial back
in 2008 on child pornography charges
where he was acquitted how is it going
to be different
i think it's going to be very different
there were 21 counts initially but then
it was reduced to 14 but as you say
those were on child pornography and
there was a tape that was introduced but
it was very grainy and i don't think the
jury really got a good sense of what was
going on and then in that case the
victim also decided that she was not
going to appear so i think that hurt the
case and he got acquitted this is very
very different the bracketeering charge
is one of the biggest differences
because we have so many witnesses that
could possibly testify and we have a
greater period of time so the
prosecution is going to have plenty of
evidence and then jesse i also think
that we now have all of the results of
the metoo movement we've seen what can
happen with the weinstein trial we've
seen what did happen with the cosby
trial even though he went on the appeal
but we know that women and other victims
have found their voices so i think
that's going to be a big difference in
this case as well all right so you have
the same defendant but very different
times and circumstance okay we also have
brian buckmeyer of course on the ground
as well now brian
also before the openings the judge made
a number of rulings tell us about that
absolutely jesse so motions in lemonade
were made and decided but before they
got to that the motion to dismiss was
denied a written decision will be given
at a different time of course we're
going to have that for our viewers when
that comes up but in terms of jane doe
number seven where the incident happened
in 1991 allegedly the judge ruled that
the witness the sexual assault can come
in but anything that happened prior to
that night to that uh
1993 date before the alleged uh
enterprise started that actually cannot
come in to jane doe number nine which
allegedly happened in 1995 that's when
we started talking about the
admissibility of the herpes because the
judge said that went to counts 12 14 and
6 through 9. also felt that based on the
allegations this wasn't too sensational
for them to bring in the issue of herpes
to j to jane doe number 11 and 12 that
evidence came in again about the herpes
and the evidence of the settlement as
evidence of concealment or furthering
the enterprise and lastly as to jane doe
14 the incident happened in 2008
allegedly that is supposedly to be
direct evidence or means of methods of
the enterprise and that's the
allegations of imprisonment and those
are allowed to come in those were the
decisions made by the judge just prior
to opening statements a little
complicated case but also i want to ask
you brian real quick before i let you go
um r kelly's demeanor it's something
we're not going to be able to see but
you get a sense of what was his reaction
what was his demeanor like in court real
quick
very stoic especially when you think of
some of the allegations where he's
accused of keeping a woman imprisoned in
a room for three days and having her pee
in a bottle uh the allegations of raping
especially when jane doe number four was
on the stand not a lot of reaction from
him very calm cool collected sending
notes to his his his attorneys i think
he understood what this case is about
and that all eyes are going to be on him
through this case no that's for sure
brian thank you so much coming up on law
and crime daily did robert durst really
kill them all the final questions his
attorneys asked him and his response
that left us all speechless
[Music]
and welcome back everybody robert durst
is back on the stand for a sixth day of
questioning as the real estate heir
tries to prove his innocence now durst
is on trial for the murder of his friend
susan berman in december 2000 he was
arrested in 2015. that's the same year
that the hbo series the jinx aired durst
had agreed to sit down with the show's
director for several interviews and in
the final scene of the docu-series durst
is heard talking to himself in a
bathroom not knowing his mic was still
hot durst says the now infamous line
killed them all of course on the stand
defense attorney dick degaran asked
durst what he meant by that statement
the situation when you're
speaking to yourself
it seems i
talk
to myself
about my thoughts
so some of what
i'm thinking
i do not state out loud
later
in the
recording of your talking to yourself
you also said
kill them all of course
yeah
what did you mean by that what i did not
say out loud
or perhaps i said very softly
because they'll all think i killed them
all of course
the defense attorney then asked durst
about his 2015 interrogation with
prosecutor john lewin prosecutors say
that durst admitted to wanting to accept
a plea deal just so he could get out of
his cell in louisiana
when mr lewin
questioned you for
several hours
almost three hours
what was going through your mind
and i should do a plea bargain with
these people
what kind of plea bargain
any kind of plea bargain
that would get me out of louisiana
if i'd been offered the right deal
i would have confessed to murdering
susan berman
to murdering kathy durst
to murdering john lennon
to murdering jack kennedy
to murdering morris black
after murdering anybody else whose name
i could think of
all right when we come back
cross-examination
how will robert durst hold up when it's
the prosecution that's asking the
questions stay with us
[Music]
welcome back cross-examination is
underway for the real estate air accused
of murdering his best friend this is the
moment that we've all been waiting for
since this trial started especially for
prosecutor john lewin and he didn't
disappoint
would you lie under oath to help your
case
yes
okay
have you lied thus far during your
testimony at this trial
no
if you had killed her you wouldn't tell
us correct correct
so given that that's the case would you
agree then that for every important
issue in this case mr durst
in essence you've just said you're not
to be believed
no
can you explain
why you say no
and if you can't you can just say i
can't explain it
for a hypothetical
did you kill susan berman
is strictly a hypothetical
i did not kill susan berman
but if i had i would lie about it
oh boy durst now admits to lying in the
stand during his first murder trial in
texas he was acquitted of the murder of
his neighbor morris black and galveston
durst now says he didn't tell the truth
about his whereabouts when susan berman
was murdered
did you tell the whole truth and nothing
but the truth during your trial
testimony in galveston
i lied
in the trial of dallaston
i said i was in northern california
when susan berman was murdered
and that was a lie
is that the only lie you told during
that trial the only one i'm aware of
and lewin went even further pressing
durst about his public lies durst denied
for years that he wrote the infamous
cadaver note but did say that whoever
wrote that note must have killed susan
berman
isn't it true mr durst that
the reason you've been caught in so many
of your lies
is that they're just not very good
well you bring up a cadaver though
and i had to lie about the cadaver note
because anyone who saw the cadaver know
would have to believe
that i was with chosen vermin when she
died
well it's worse than that mr durst you
previously said on multiple occasions
that quote that's a note only the killer
could have written
correct
that's what andrew asked me to say that
that's another thing that mr director
asked you to say did he ask you to say
it when you were speaking to me as well
in 2015.
and you hear durst there blaming the
jinx director for what he said terry
absolutely incredible but if we get into
this lewin's cross-examination it's
mostly focused on multiple
inconsistencies endure statements over
the years but which ones are really
important and which ones might the jury
just overlook or kind of excuse
well there are so many inconsistencies
jesse both in public both under oath
both when he's talking to directly the
director for the jinx but i think the
most important inconsistency obviously
is the cadaver note because that is the
note that really does implicate him in
the death of susan berman and the fact
that he had to admit he wrote that note
because clearly he misspelled the word
beverly and the handwriting was the same
as the envelope i think the one area and
this is just a small criticism because i
think lewin is doing an amazing
cross-examination one of the best
crosses i've ever seen but i would not
have started out talking about the games
that he played when he was a child with
his mother who cares if it is you know
uno or whether or not he played other
games and apparently uno wasn't around
when his mother passed away but i think
that's a very small point and i think i
would have saved that or not even talked
about it at all but he brought that up
in the very beginning of the cross and
it's one of the things that i think he
should have saved for later or as i said
not said anything at all and you make a
great point but maybe him admitting to
lying about some things makes him more
credible in the lines of the jury i
don't know we'll wait and see terry
thank you so much that's all we have for
you thanks for joining us here on long
prime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you